happy birthday here's to many more
here's your birthday I'd like to say if
you work I've been on this earth for 80
years after the lot of thought I would
like to make an announcement I'm going
back to Oregon I want to do I stopped
it's my birthday honey I could say what
I want
go on honey would you pass the bread
please I don't want to lose it any more
and you want to start here as much as I
want to go here I like you got it all
worked out I'm not having some stranger
driving who else do you have in mind
don't even think about it no one forced
you to take it not saying that you did
when it sounds like you are it is so
much more pleasant than traveling with
the stranger in Drive left for another
day they're going to run out of steam
like your chef exciting we get universal
it's for customers only we have a $10
minimum I was my father I'm driving him
to Oregon so that he can kill itself we
good here
and your verbs there oh yeah crowd you
ever considered viagra you talk to me
when you're hard on trying to mashed
potatoes keep it down here's your mail
we're hearing Danny look away
thank you mom turn them around right now
I'm flying out there and I'm taking over
all right I just real with one family to
talk Turkey the time
why are you here
you all gave up on me a long time ago
you got the whole family get on for a
long time
[Music]
you